Tor zur Zukunft so nennt sich hamburgs
Hafen gern und Zukunft ohne China das
mag man sich hier nicht vorstellen
längst hängen andere Häfen Hamburg ab
weil sie so die Argumentation
chinesische Reedereien als Anteilseigner
haben und die sorgen für gute Auslastung
deswegen möchte Hamburg 35% des
Terminals toller Ort an das chinesische
Staatsunternehmen cosco verkaufen gar
nicht toll findet dass der
Justizminister gerade auf USA-Reise
meine persönliche Ansicht ist dass wir
die Fehler die wir in der Beziehung zu
Russland gemacht haben also ein sehr
abhängig zu machen dass wir die nicht im
Verhältnis zu China wiederholen dürfen
und deshalb ist meine generelle
Überzeugung dass China und auch die
chinesische Regierung keine Kontrolle
über kritische Infrastruktur in
Deutschland bekommen sollte
Robert Habeck wollte heute nichts dazu
sagen sein Ministerium aber hatte das
investitionsprüfverfahren auf den Weg
gegeben dass zu dem Schluss kam die
Chinesen sollten den Zuschlag nicht
bekommen weitere fünf Ministerien sehen
das auch so eigentlich hätte die Sache
im Kabinett damit gestoppt werden müssen
das Kanzleramt aber habe den Punkt nicht
auf die Tagesordnung gesetzt so
Recherchen von NDR und WDR und wenn
cosco nicht aufgehalten wird dann findet
der Deal Ende Oktober statt was ist die
Gefahr zum einen haben wir Risiken mit
Blick auf mögliche Spionage
datenabschlüsse viel wichtiger scheint
mir und das zeigt der Fall ja jetzt
schon die Möglichkeit der politischen
Einflussnahme auf
Entscheidungsprozesse in der Regierung
der Kanzler scheint den Verkauf
durchdrücken zu wollen ganz auf seiner
Seite ist der erste Bürgermeister von
Hamburg er findet die Idee mit dem
Terminal toller Ort nach wie vor toll
eine Ablehnung der cosco-beteiligung
durch die Bundesregierung ist im
Hinblick auf die Nation Sicherheit und
Unabhängigkeit nicht begründbar sie wäre
eine schwere Belastung für den
Wirtschaftsstandort und eine einseitige
wettbewerbsverzerrende Benachteiligung
Hamburgs gegenüber Rotterdam und
Antwerpen in denen cosco bereits
Terminal Anteile besitzt doch kaum einer
geht hier mit es gibt eine einhellige
Bewertung der Fachministerien dass diese
Beteiligung
von einem chinesischen Unternehmen was
im Zweifelsfall vom Staat angeführt
werden würde
schwierig ist für unsere Souveränität
und Unabhängigkeit und alle in der
Bundesregierung sind angehalten diese
Souveränität zu verteidigen
die Front gegen Scholz ist heute breit
und wütend und mächtig selbst aus seiner
eigenen Partei kommt viel Unverständnis
später Einsicht bei vielen denn
unabhängig ist Deutschland in Bezug auf
China längst nicht mehr noch viel
stärker als ein Russland hängt unser
Wohlstand an chinasmarkt seinen
Produkten seinen Investitionen das gilt
auch für andere der ein Parteienstaat
hat sich strategisch aufgestellt mit
europaweiten Beteiligungen an mehr als
einem Dutzend helfen das weiß auch die
Opposition das ist eine Machtposition
die gesucht wird und entwickelt worden
ist und wenn es zum Konflikt kommt wird
von dieser Macht Gebrauch gemacht
eine neue Machtposition nun also am Tor
zur Zukunft in Hamburg Hafen der Kanzler
will das wohl nicht verhindern
ja ein großes Thema das wollen wir noch
vertiefen mit unseren Korrespondenten in
Berlin und Peking zunächst zu Theo Koll
könnte aus diesem hafengeschäft so ein
ähnlich großer koalitionskraft werden
wenn werden wie zuletzt bei der
Atomkraft nur diesmal halt mit anders
verteilten Rollen Kanzler gegen den Rest
ja also jedenfalls ist der Kanzler
zusammen mit dem Hamburger Bürgermeister
recht Einsammeln der Ampel und auch in
der politischen Beurteilung dass das
alles nicht so schlimm sei alle mit der
Frage befassten Ministerien sind gegen
den Verkauf an China und für viele ist
es seine Art chinesische Parallele zu
denen an Russland verkauften
gasspeichern auch wenn es nur ein
kleiner Teil des Hafens ist damit würden
dennoch Teile von kritischer
Infrastruktur und auch wichtige
logistikeinblicke in chinesische Hände
gegeben über den Hamburger Hafen sollen
soweit ich weiß künftig ja zentrale
Teile unserer Energieversorgung mit
grünem Wasserstoff laufen und wenn es
stimmt was über den jetzt schon
ausgeübten massiven chinesischen
lobbydruck zu hören ist dann stellt sich
wirklich die Frage der eigenen
nationalen Verwundbarkeit selbst bei
einem dann doch relativ überschaubaren
Investment nun gibt es ja so viele
Warnungen vor den Absichten Chinas und
selbst deutsche Geheimdienste schlagen
Alarm wird das denn im Kanzleramt in den
Wind geschlagen
nein das Kanzleramt weiß natürlich ganz
genau wie abhängig Deutschland von China
ist und wie groß die Gefahr ist Chinas
Wirtschaft ist elf Mal so groß wie die
russische und wenn China uns nicht mehr
beliefern würde beispielsweise wegen
Taiwan Sanktionen dann steht hier jede
zweite Produktionsanlage Stille Olaf
Scholz will weg von dieser Abhängigkeit
und hat auch schon auf dem g7-gipfel in
Ellmau ja eine
multipolare Strategie verkündet aber
solange es diesen neuen Markt in der
Welt für die deutsche Wirtschaft nicht
gibt will er das vorhandene natürlich
nicht aufgeben es dürfte interessant
werden wie die künftige china-strategie
aussieht die gerade bei Frau beerburg im
Auswärtigen Amt er arbeitet wird
letztlich geht es dabei auch um die
Frage welchen Preis sind wir als
Gesellschaft bereit zu zahlen für unsere
Unabhängigkeit und auf wie viel
Wohlstand verzichten wir im kleinen
zeigt sich das jetzt im Hamburger Hafen
dann schauen wir uns die chinesischen
Absichten dabei mal näher an mit unserer
Korrespondentin Miriam Steiner in Peking
Miriam warum interessiert man sich in
Peking so sehr für europäische Häfen
kurzfristig geht es ums Geschäft seine
Investitionen die profitabwerfen soll
und das geht darum dass chinesische
Waren im Hamburger Hafen bevorzugt
abgefertigt werden
interessanter ist vielleicht das
langfristige Interesse cosco ist ein
Beispiel für Staatskapitalismus die
Kommunistische Partei hat direkten
Einfluss auf das Unternehmen und deshalb
jetzt nicht nur um die Interessen des
Unternehmens sondern um die Interessen
des chinesischen Staates wir haben schon
gehört China ist beteiligt an mehr als
einem Dutzend europäischer Häfen china
will diesen Markt beherrschen und die
Dominanz ausnutzen als geostrategisches
Instrument wir haben bei den Projekten
der neuen Seidenstraße ja schon
anschaulich gesehen dass China
Wirtschaftsprojekte benutzt um seinen
Einfluss in der Welt auszuweiten und um
sich chinesische Interessen zu vertreten
und die reichen dann von dem Abgreifen
von Know-how bis hin zur Kontrolle
chinesischer Bürgerinnen und Bürger in
Übersee
nun könnte man ja sagen okay aber China
ist von uns ja auch dann wirtschaftlich
abhängig aber das hat sich bei Putin ja
auch schon als ein Denkfehler erwiesen
ja in der chinesischen Denkweise ist es
genau andersrum china will sich in
wichtigen Schlüsselindustrien unabhängig
machen das hat der chinesische Präsident
hier den pingen auch hier beim Parteitag
in Peking diese Woche noch mal betont es
geht um die nationale Sicherheit das ist
seine Prämisse beim cosco-deal testet er
auch wie weit ergehen kann er hat
signalisiert dass eine Weigerung
Deutschlands wirtschaftliche
Konsequenzen haben könnte es geht bei
seinen wirtschaftlichen Ambitionen auch
darum sich machtpolitisch Beinfreiheit
zu verschaffen zum Beispiel bei einem
möglichen Angriff Chinas auf Taiwan käme
es ihm gelegen ein großes Druckmittel
gegen den Westen zu haben und da kann
die Kontrolle über europäische Häfen
natürlich helfen aus deutscher
Perspektive mag es also kurzfristig
vielleicht ein gutes Geschäft sein
dieser koskodil aber langfristig kann es
wirklich ein Problem für die nationale
Sicherheit Europas sein
der Chef des deutschen
Verfassungsschutzes Thomas Haldenwang
hat das ja kürzlich so formuliert ist
der Sturm und China ist der Klimawandel
danke euch beiden nach Peking und Berlin